the lapd has released video evidence
from a police shooting last week that
killed a 14 year old girl it happened at
a department store after officers
responded to reports that a man with a
gun was assaulting people an officer
confronted that man shot the suspect but
also hit the girl who was trying on
clothes with her mother jonathan
vigliotti has the story and we warn you
that some of the video is disturbing
police body camera footage shows
multiple lapd officers arriving at this
north hollywood burlington department
store with their guns drawn after
receiving calls of an assault and a
possible shooting in progress
just a guy with that gun moments before
police arrived surveillance video
captured the suspect attacking multiple
customers with what appeared to be a
bicycle lock the officers moved quickly
to the second floor where they found 24
year old suspect daniel elena lopez near
a woman he was beating with the lock
an officer then opens fire killing lopez
unknown to all at the time one shot
pierced a wall behind the suspect and
struck and killed 14 year old valentina
orolana peralta who was in a dressing
room with her mother officers recovered
the bicycle lock at the scene but no gun
was found on the suspect what exactly
did the officer see
and why did the officer choose to fire
his firearm law enforcement expert brian
higgins says there are more questions
than answers right now the agency i'm
sure is going to investigate
how three shots were fired with a long
weapon only one hit the suspect and
maybe one that missed hit the innocent
victim lapd police chief michael moore
told our cbs affiliate kcbs that the use
of deadly force is always the last
resort we're doing whatever we can to
gather as much to be as transparent as
possible
the officer who fired the rounds has
been placed on paid administrative leave
pending an internal investigation for
cbs morning's jonathan bigliotti los
angeles
it seems that lapd wanted to clear this
up very quickly releasing that video so
soon usually they wait a period of time
yeah it's just so unfortunate a young
lady with her mother trying on clothes
senseless tragic
her heart goes out to valentina and her
family yes that's for sure